a thousand pound sister star Amy Slayton
and her husband Michael Halterman
splitting up Michael reportedly filed
for divorce after four years of marriage
ET has reached out for confirmation a
whole lot of Hassle and headache
this comes less than a year after the
former couple welcomed their second
child Glenn together having a baby means
the world to me is everything I've
always wanted Amy and Michael are also
parents to two-year-old Gage the reality
star documented her pregnancy on season
two of the TLC series I'm pregnant
are you serious I told him to check it
four times but there's so many unknowns
with this pregnancy anything could go
wrong at the time Amy had recently
undergone weight loss surgery and
doctors warned her of the risk involved
with conceiving not long after the
procedure
it's only been a couple months since I
had the surgery and Dr Proctor told me
not to get pregnant for two years
oops
but honestly it ain't really my fault
because I don't know how Devil's to
birth control I am disappointed that
they weren't able to wait the full two
years before getting pregnant because
even though Amy's lost a lot of weight
she's still a very high risk pregnancy
at 288 pounds plus this is going to put
a huge damper on her overall weight loss
there's a tendency to say hey I'm
pregnant we can eat whatever we want to
and for you this is in the middle of a
big weight loss Journey meanwhile Amy's
sister 10
role of her health too
but this is gonna help
me in the long run and as Amy's Love
Story comes to an end Tammy's is just
beginning fans can look forward to
seeing her marry her now husband Caleb
as season four continues to play out but
ahead of the numptuals Tammy's family
shared their skepticism over the
marriage
are you perky
shotgun wedding
nobody's having a shotgun word well I
mean it is awful soon
the heck
are you pregnant
this is crazy I can't believe my family
thinks I'm getting married because I'm
pregnant
[Music]